[Música]
foi então que os brancos muito legais
convidaram a gente para uma festa deles
dizendo que era pra gente também negócio
de livros sobre a gente
eles estavam tão ocupados ensinando o
monte de coisa procure o léo dá pra da
platéia que nem repararam que apertassem
um pouco até dava pra abrir um espacinho
e todo mundo de repente sentar junto na
mesa mas a gente foi
eles que fizeram ea gente não podia
bagunçar com essa de chega pra cá chega
pra lá a gente tinha que ser educado e
era discurso e mais discurso tudo com
muito aplauso
foi aí que a negrinha que estava sentada
com a gente deu uma de atrevida tinham
chamado ela para responder uma pergunta
ela se levantou foi lá na mesa pegou um
microfone e começou a reclamar por causa
de certas coisas que estavam acontecendo
na festa
pronto estava armada a kizomba a negrada
parecia que estava esperando por isso
queriam bagunçar tudo e era um tal de
falar alto gritava haia que nem dava
mais pra ouvir discurso nenhum
onde é que já se viu isso se eles sabiam
da gente mais do que a gente mesmo
teve uma hora que não deu pra aguentar
aquela zoada toda negra ignorante e mal
educado
foi aí que um branco enfezado partiu pra
cima de um [ __ ] que tinha pegado no
microfone para falar contra os brancos
ea festa acabou como
em briga agora aqui pra nós
quem teve a culpa
aquela linha teve vida ora se não
tivesse dado com a língua nos dentes
agora ela está queimada entre os brancos
também e mandou não saber se comportar
lélia gonzales racismo e sexismo na
cultura brasileira é bom dia eu sou hoje
eu vou na xavier
eu tenho 39 anos eu vou colocar esse
papel no chão
é eu me tornei professora concursada da
universidade federal do rio de janeiro
com 34 anos e eu estou aqui hoje pra
contar um pouco dessa história
a primeira coisa que eu acho importante
no mundo de hoje é a gente poder ter o
direito de se apresentar como muitas em
uma só
então eu costumo me apresentar dessa
forma como uma mulher que condensa
muitas versões em uma só
então eu sou giovanna eu sou a
professora da faculdade na ufrj sua
coordenadora de intelectuais negras do
grupo pet diversidade
a colunista do nexo jornal eu também sou
a mãe do peri
eu sou a filha da sônia a neta da leoa
eu sou a dançarina já eu sou surfista em
muitas outras identidades que eu carrego
no meu corpo que também são cora na sãs
e strass que me antecederam e é a partir
desse lugar que eu tô aqui hoje pra
contar um pouco do trabalho de
transformar margens em centros
você pode substituir mulheres negras
como objeto de estudos por mulheres
negras
contando a sua história
pensem um pouco nessa frase que essa
frase
nos ensina pensando na sociedade
brasileira
ao lado dessa frase a gente tem esse
gráfico cheio de dados científicos
estatísticas estatísticas são números
são vidas são pessoas
então a gente tem esse gráfico mostrando
um pouco da história da produção do
conhecimento científico na universidade
num universo de 258 bolsistas de
produtividade do conselho nacional de
desenvolvimento científico e tecnológico
o nosso cnpq 250 são mulheres brancas e
apenas oito mulheres negros e aí a gente
volta pra fra ok
dentro desse universo de produção de
conhecimento científico uma das coisas
que costumam muito me perguntar é mas
giovanna o intelectuais negras é um
grupo incrível a disciplina maravilhosa
todas as iniciativas são fantásticas mas
vocês conhecem essa teoria da
adversidade mas porém contudo entretanto
é então mais quais são suas referências
então aqui eu tenho algumas das minhas
referências que são mulheres que também
contribuem pra transgredir os sentidos
de produção de conhecimento e saberes
que a gente produz dentro e fora da
universidade
a invisibilidade é a morte em vida já
dizia a soeda loreto da trindade a
importância da arte do palavra ser
escutada que vem na fala potente da
escritora miriam alves
e à pergunta central da nossa grande
conceição evaristo o que levaria
determinadas mulheres nas cidades e
criadas em ambientes não letrados e
quando muitos semialfabetizados a romper
com a passividade da leitura e buscarem
o movimento da escrita
o que vocês acham que levaria o que
essas três perguntas se relacionam de
que forma essas duas perguntas se
relacionam à eu estar aqui na frente
hoje quando eu recebi o convite para
participar desse ted sabe qual foi a
primeira coisa que eu pensei nossa
incrível me convidaram exatamente para o
lugar onde eu deveria está no centro da
narrativa
e olha que eu nem sabia que a testar o
apetite vermelho aqui mas eu tô achando
ele um barco super providencial e eu to
de vermelho também então acho que é uma
boa composição pra gente pensar nos
centros e nas margens e na arte do falar
pra ser escutado em como nós construímos
as nossas referências é dentro desse
projeto chamado intelectuais negras que
um grupo de estudos e pesquisas que foi
criado em 2014 na companhia de outras
mulheres negras entre elas qual dl pavão
janete santos ribeiro marta muniz bento
e célia cristo
a gente tem uma proposta que se desdobra
em várias uma das mais conhecidas é a
disciplina intelectuais negros que é uma
disciplina eletiva da faculdade de
educação que atende estudantes
universitários não só da ufrj mas de
todas as universidades
eu costumo dizer no primeiro dia dos
intelectuais negras e eu não estou
conseguindo ver ninguém mas eu sei que
nós estamos por aí muitas fortes e
visíveis e e aqui também
eu costumo dizer no primeiro dia de aula
que intelectuais negras é uma disciplina
qual nós vamos ficar durante um semestre
estudando falando lendo e comentando
única e exclusivamente o pensamento ea
produção oral e escrita de mulheres
negros e que se porventura alguém não
estiver satisfeito com que a disciplina
oferece a casa oferta 99.9 por cento de
outras possibilidades estão pensando
intelectuais negras como esse 0.1 por
cento
eu tenho também ressignificado meu
trabalho pensado que mais do que
transgredir os currículos acadêmicos
o que nós temos feito na verdade é
trazer uma proposta de normatização do
currículo acadêmico porque a
normatização da sociedade brasileira é
de novo as estatísticas o conhecimento
científico ea e dessa vez nos dados do
instituto brasileiro geraldo de
estatísticas é composto por uma maioria
de população negra com uma
expressividade do grupo feminino de
mulheres
então nada mais normatizador do que
produzir conhecimento na universidade
tendo como centro da narrativa as
subjetividades a produção eo pensamento
de mulheres negras e isso não é uma
transgressão é uma normatização é e aí a
gente parte dessa perspectiva
também pensando que nos tempos atuais
têm sido cada vez mais importante a
gente também reivindicá o universalismo
a partir das nossas experiências então
mais do que trabalhar com projetos anti
racistas a gente está disputando um
sentido de democracia em que o
protagonismo às agências ea produção de
conhecimento de mulher
as negras constituam o centro dessas
narrativas bom estar no centro da
narrativa também nos coloca diante de
algumas perguntas que são perguntas
importantes de serem apresentadas de
novo você pode substituir mulheres
negras como objeto de estudos por
mulheres negras contando a sua própria
história
e aí eu pergunto quem tem o direito de
ser considerada intelectual na sociedade
brasileira
geralmente quando eu faço essa pergunta
a resposta vem com outras perguntas
porque intelectuais negras e não somente
intelectuais
eu como uma mulher branca
posso falar posso estudar mulheres
negras é porque uma disciplina e não um
projeto de extensão
todas essas são perguntas que se
articulam a uma disputa de narrativas
sobre quem tem o direito de ser chamado
de intelectual na sociedade brasileira
mas mais do que isso essas perguntas
sinalizam também caminhos que são
percorridos para construir essa
intelectuais da intelectualidade e que
tem sido historicamente invisibilizados
então eu gosto sempre de lembrar que por
exemplo quando mulheres trabalhadoras
domésticas organizam o seu modo de
trabalho limpando por último a cozinha
da casa existe um saber embutido nessa
organização porque limpa por último a
cozinha tem a ver com ter a compreensão
a leitura de mundo de que a cozinha o
espaço da casa mais utilizado e por seu
espaço mais utilizado
ele é o espaço que precisa ser limpo por
último caso contrário essa trabalhadora
vai ficar o dia inteiro na função
cozinha como a gente tanto ver por aí e
naturaliza é esse são saberes difíceis
de entrar pela porta da frente da
academia mas a gente também vai
aprendendo que elton sapato bonito não
sei se dá pra ver o pé na porta pode ser
dado de diversas formas não fosse aquele
pé
pode ser que ele é né
e então essas são histórias que precisam
ser contadas e de certa forma esse é o
meu trabalho na universidade federal do
rio de janeiro como que eu posso
visibilizar saberes que foram
historicamente tecidos pela minha
estreia lidade por mim mesma e por
tantas outras que me cercam nas salas de
aulas nas famílias nas comunidades nos
movimentos sociais e que não são
reconhecidas como produtoras de saber
essa é uma questão que traz uma segunda
como agente articula conquistas
individuais com ganhos coletivos
se a gente se pergunta qual é o papel ou
melhor tem o direito de ser considerado
um intelectual na sociedade brasileira
uma vez que a gente tem esse direito
assegurado como a gente faz pra
multiplicar né pra distribuir o
conhecimento de uma maneira democrática
e eu acho que uma das respostas têm a
ver com colocar no centro da da
narrativa diversas formas de definir
essa essa intelectualidade
é bom e aí a gente entra numa pauta que
pra mim tem sido muito importante
o auto cuidado a gente está falando de
um país que historicamente colocou
mulheres negras como objeto como figuras
hipersexualização dadas como não humanas
ou como mulheres criadas para servir
nesse sentido o conceito de transgressão
é um conceito importante porque as
nossas histórias transgridem esses
lugares que nos foram impostos caso
contrário eu não estaria aqui por
exemplo e por isso eu costumo dizer que
nós não somos sobreviventes mulheres
negras são antes de mais nada viventes
né nós temos o poder nas nossas mãos de
reinventar refazer as nossas próprias
histórias e determinar os lugares que
nós queremos estar por mais que todo o
tempo o mundo nos force a pensar o
contrário
e nesse sentido o conceito de auto
cuidado é algo importante é o direito de
cuidar de si e de perceber que para
cuidar dos outros você precisa estar bem
primeiramente com você mesma é um
direito historicamente negado e um país
em que mulheres negras são
fundamentalmente pensadas como a mãe
preta da sociedade brasileira é somos
mães também e antes de mais nada só
podemos ser mães porque somos seres
humanos e ao sermos seres humanos somos
em vários momentos super heroínas do tal
pé na porta mas também somos mulheres
frágeis são as mulheres com sentimentos
com emoções com contradições e com
inquietações no coração de como colocar
em prática os nossos sentidos de
liberdade e de direito à vida
tudo isso tem a ver com cuidar de si
tudo isso tem a ver com as revoluções
internas que nós provocamos e como a
professora universitária
por mais que eu acho que seja difícil
dizer que mulheres negras têm
privilégios porque quando eu saio da
ufrj e mesmo dentro dela eu sou apenas
mais uma mulher negra
por mais que haja essa constatação ela
coexiste com outras potências muito
bonitas que a sala de aula proporciona é
bom e aí quais são essas potências
o lima barreto tem uma frase que eu
gosto muito é a minha frase favorita
dele eu sou uma leitora compulsiva do
lima barreto
ele fala o seguinte ou a literatura me
mata
ou me down que eu peço eu gosto de
parafrasear pensando na minha trajetória
acadêmica ou academia me mata
ou me dá o que eu peço é o que eu peço
pra academia o que afinal quero da
academia para responder essa pergunta eu
vou contar uma história é uma história
da sala de aula poderia contar várias
mas eu escolhi conta essa essa história
aconteceu essa história baseada em fatos
reais
ela aconteceu no curso intelectuais
negras deste semestre e foi o seguinte a
gente estava numa outra atividade fora
da sala de aula e um estudante me chamou
posso falar com você sim pode claro nas
mãos dela tinha um pequeno pote
plástico ela olhou pra mim e falou eu
vim aqui pra te entregar esse pote
dentro desse pote tem uma paçoca caseira
que eu faço com a minha avó é eu trouxe
esse pote pra você porque a sua sala de
aula me lembra muito a ancestralidade
espiritualidade e quem eu fui no passado
por mais que eu não tenho o direito de
conhecer essa minha história passada
então poderia dizer aquilo que eu peço
da universidade é que as histórias das
paróquias entrem pela porta da frente e
sejam reconhecidas como as nossas
histórias como os nossos saberes mas uma
coisa mais importante que eu peço para a
universidade e não é o pedido generoso e
cordial esperado por uma certa ideia de
academia senhorial é o pedido da
negociação é o pedido do conflito é o
pedido da barganha mas também o conflito
da harmonia do sorriso do amor da paixão
que move a gente faz a gente produzir o
conhecimento o que eu peço pra academia
é que a gente tenha a sabedoria de
reinventar os sentidos de
intelectualidade e como é que se faz
hoje essa reinvenção dos sentidos de
intelectualidade essa reinvenção
ela só pode ser feita antes de mais nada
conferindo espaço pra sujeito que são
considerados não sujeito contarem suas
próprias histórias
vem aí a idéia de narrativas na primeira
pessoa
não por acaso eu assino como preta
doutora na primeira pessoa e costuma
perguntar qual é o problema é ser preta
ou ec doutora os dois é demais né é
muita coisa
para o brasil meu brasil brasileiro bem
a gente pede que é a academia se
organize e reveja a sua forma
majoritária né
também chamada hegemônica de produção de
conhecimento
quando a gente ouvir frases como
professora eu não posso me considerar
uma intelectual porque eu nunca saí do
país
eu não posso me considerar uma
intelectual porque eu não sei falar
inglês
eu não posso me considerar intelectual
porque eu sou a primeira da minha
família entrar na universidade
eu não posso me considerar intelectual
porque aquele professor me disse naquela
aula que eu vou ser balconista essas
falas sinalizam a importância não de
lutar apenas por um projeto anti racista
da sociedade brasileira
essas falas sinalizam a urgência e neve
teu inevitabilidade de trabalhar com o
cotidiano a mente por um sentido de
universidade de produção de conhecimento
que seja de fato democrático ea
democracia radical na universidade passa
por reconhecer o protagonismo de
mulheres negras como ocupantes do centro
da narrativa na formação da história do
brasil
ora isso significa também voltar a frase
que são importantes na história do
pensamento das mulheres negros como por
exemplo nossos passos vêm de longe
conhecem essa frase é uma hashtag que
circula bastante nas redes sociais na
realidade do dos feminismos negros de
pensar que eu tô aqui hoje pelas
mulheres de ontem né
por lélia gonzales azul do loreto da
trindade beatriz nascimento que
costumava dizer que a favela é o nosso
grande quilombo
então por tartá
aqui hoje nesse lugar nesse centro desse
palco nesse centro da narrativa
eu quero dizer que não existe um único
sentido de ser intelectual negra
historicamente nós fomos privadas do
acesso à cultura escrita que a maneira
pela qual a academia principalmente se
organiza
ao mesmo tempo nós desenvolvemos uma
série de códigos culturais pra fazer
valer os nossos saberes né os nossos
potinhos de de paçoca e sem esses
potinhos de paçoca com certeza eu não
estaria aqui hoje
então eu quero terminar com essa imagem
é ea música falando um pouco desses
espaços que que vem de longe
é essa imagem sou eu mas também não sou
só eu sou mais stephanes as marílias
natália e das palomas que estão aqui
sentadas e muitas outras
e essa é uma imagem que tem a ver com a
ancestralidade que eu carrego tem a ver
com as donas do meu ori né
eu sou uma filha de iansã e de oxum e
por isso eu sou uma mulher metá metá
metade correnteza dos rios metade ventos
e tempestades
então que as nossas histórias continuem
ventando e se movimentando no curso dos
rios das universidades
aliás dentro e fora d
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]